you're full alive on the day of net
neutrality we might not be broadcasting
anymore hmm might be over I don't know
how that works when does it kick in
right away I don't know I have no idea
by the way is there ever been like a
harder time to be a citizen meaning like
it's just how much I never had to pay
this much attention I know right like
come on it's like [ __ ] we have to
babysit it's like they're children that
we have to like wait what are they doing
no like where they used to kind of be
able to take care of themselves
yeah or seemingly could there's not one
place where you can go where you can get
one hunting that before you yes you're
not checking maniac bro I don't give up
it's gonna explode all over those let
that [ __ ] rest though the worst ones
are those little small ones that I have
those cayenne cleanses you shake those
[ __ ] they just [ __ ] shoot up to the
ceiling is that true you know it's all
fermented yeah carbonated you know yeah
but there's no one source where you can
absolutely get 100% unbiased factual
information as the news everything is
leaning one way or leaning another way
and even CNN which I used to trust all
the time they [ __ ] up all the time
they're always having to print
retractions there was something that was
going around today it's just there's not
one news source where I can say please
just give me the unbiased information
with no left or right lean yeah I get
that which is hot which we talked about
beforehand be when there's but like even
the idea of the New York Times what I
what people don't understand it people
don't understand journalism a lot of the
time like literally when people go it's
fake news it's like you know you can't
print fake news because they you ever
you ever have anything in The New Yorker
you ever be quoted in New York article I
they literally you talk to the
journalist then two different fact
checkers call you to confirm what you
said and like it's this true right is
that and I literally this is in an
article about someone else that I gave a
quote for and like did you say that
and you can confirm that and they do
that they do that it mage every major
journalistic outfit they did the New
York Times Washington Post that like
name the big ones they all have they're
not as stringent as the New York as The
New Yorker because in here only comes
out once a week but they all have fact
checkers and they can get and the thing
is these institutions can get sued right
this is not a good example but it's it's
an example the Conor McGregor fight mmm
New York Times wrote an article about
the Conor McGregor fight and one of the
things they said that he was covered in
blood and rescued by the referee before
he fell through the rooms I contacted
them on Twitter and I said you in this
day and age you can't say things that
everyone knows are false yet millions of
people watched that fight there was no
blood yeah he was not falling through
the ropes
referee rescued him he made that up he
was outclassed and battered by a far
superior boxer which is what most boxing
people expected that's the real story
yeah but you guys added a bunch of [ __ ]
to it yeah so they might rotate it
that's for sure yeah it's not just
shading it's yeah it's a straight lie I
know it's not a because it's not it
really it doesn't there's
inconsequential it's not really
something yeah it's not like a big
moment time and the result is the same
but their description of the result
makes you wonder how much other things
do you do this - how many other subjects
do you flavor in this weird way
what was their attraction because I
remember seeing you right there as a
yeah it's cool like yeah and they they
change it even but they still use
hyperbole even in their retraction they
said his face was completely swollen it
wasn't it wasn't a quadrant of his face
a tiny amount of swelling from a boxing
match not like not some crazy like
[ __ ] Hasim Rahman [ __ ] had an iron on
his head literally the fun like maybe
the craziest thing I've ever seen in a
fight it was disgusting this huge
hematoma growing out of his forehead she
did find that yeah Hasim Rahman yeah
Lennox Lewis right it wasn't Lennox
Lewis fight you know I don't remember
but yeah it was like he literally had
dr. pimple pop you that Oh dr. pimple
robber that's hilarious
like that that was great with a wild
that was an enormous swelling in his
head he looks like a war criminal and an
alien yeah so if that you mean yeah they
do they do Shade invariably but you
shouldn't you shouldn't you should tell
the exact store the exact story was
really clear for everybody that watched
the two million people plus that watched
it on pay-per-view or more it wasn't
something that you can get away with
bullshitting about okay but do you know
him five years ago do you know a man
like it wasn't like it wasn't a problem
it wasn't a problem day-to-day and
that's the thing that I was yelling at
somebody yesterday of like the once peep
once Fox News created this thing of like
extremely shaded [ __ ] and people saw
there's a market for it
they're like all right we'll do that
like wall do that now yeah and then
everyone's everyone's reacting but they
don't think they're reacting but and now
the New York Times is trying to go the
other way where they're they hired this
guy Bret Stevens to write op-ed pieces
and every week there's a new like what
did you just say like you know yeah
because they're trying to be like
they're trying to be kind of moderate or
see both sides and a lot of people on
the left are going like but that's how
are you seeing both sides to like
slavery like the [ __ ] you talking about
like what's both sides of climate change
right it's all they're scientists and
not scientists that's like those the
side so why are you this is basically
appeasement
I guess as of the as a uh you know
consumer this stuff it's when I was to
get into this conference I wasn't even
talking about journalism I was talking
about government I was talking about the
amount of [ __ ] work it takes just to
be like to like I got to worry about
statutes and [ __ ] the FCC and [ __ ]
executive orders and just like I never
had to do all this yeah like why is this
so much I don't know if it's I mean they
would say like you know to be an act of
democracy it's only as good as citizens
and all that [ __ ] but but it seems like
we're all more involved and it's worse
you know I mean like it's like it's way
more upsetting it's P constant upset
like it feels like havoc every single
day